you have a weatherman on the show he's
played by Brad Pitt no that's not
official he looks a lot like Brad Pitt
it was a guy ranked the guy who's Brad
Pitt right and look at that suit you got
Brad Pitt wearing this is the thing this
is the thing so Brad Pitt calls me up
and he likes my stand-up he said I want
to be on your show and it literally the
phone calls this quick I went do you
want to be my weatherman and he went
yeah yeah okay great and now he's the
weatherman he's like the nicest man in
the world so he gave his brown suit and
then after he's like hey um can I take
that with me and I'm like yeah and now
he carries the suit around with him in
case he wants to do some field work
weather reporting sometimes he just
sends me weather reports from his iPhone
these film doing so extraordinary that
is you've got like the biggest store in
the world sent begging to be on your
show then we pay him $400 in episode
he's very reasonable cuz that's like the
sag minimum like the after the actors
Union yeah you have to pay a certain
amount and it's would it be rude to go I
will give you a thousand that's just
insulting it's more complimentary to get
him nothing right right
you